[Music]
our world has shrunk into the 30
centimeters between our eyes and our
smartphone
we are all zoomed in
let's stop that and zoom out instead
learn about the universe and your life
will change forever
for the better
my crash course in astronomy
will give you a fresh look at your own
existence
a new perspective on life
and a gentle way to view the world and
the people on it
so put your smartphones away for a
minute
give yourself some space in the most
literal sense
don't look down at your screen
look up at the stars
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
ladies and gentlemen you are in for a
treat
coming to us today is an author that i
have uh loved his work from the time i
first encountered him and scientific
american uh to his previous book
uh ripples in space time
the einstein gravitational waves in the
future of astronomy which featured uh
my favorite cmb experiment uh at least
until this book came out that was a
bicep 2 is featured heavily in this book
some friends of the show like barry
barrish ray weiss kip thorne are in that
book but this book
features the simon's observatory and so
we got to talk about that but it's uh
governor chilling who is a dutch writer
originally but he is uh one of my
favorite authors i love this book i love
all your writing sky and telescope
everywhere i find you go over it
shilling how are you doing today sir
i'm very doing very well brian thanks
for having me on your podcast and i'm
especially doing very well because i'm
not in my home country the netherlands
but i'm in sweden in the north of europe
because my daughter who lives here
was married just two days ago so uh i'm
happy congratulations thank you what
could be
what could be better every father of
young girls and older girls dreams of
the day when that will happen and then
she's somebody else's problem now i'm
just kidding we love our girls the girls
are the best i have uh in both of my
girls rooms i have posters of maria
gephardt mayer and all these scientists
i don't know what your daughter is
interested in but um but coming from the
netherlands i wonder if you've always
had kind of a natural inclination
towards the telescope and the microscope
because you can tell us
what is the connection between the
telescope and the microscope
of course since uh both instruments were
first developed in the netherlands but i
didn't learn about that uh after i uh
before i started to become interested in
astronomy as a young teenager boy that
was in the apollo days in the 1960s
i got hooked on astronomy i
had a saturday job in a supermarket so i
saved some money to buy a telescope
became a member of a youth association
here in the netherlands and what i did
was make drawings of the moon and of the
planets and all those kind of things and
i love to read because i've always loved
to read books and i've also always loved
to write about the topics that i love so
when i was a member of this youth
association in the netherlands i also
started to write for them
and
that's how it all started and
that's one of the reasons why i never
took up an academic study in astronomy
which i never have done because it just
was my hobby
and um so in a sense i've turned my
hobby into a profession and that's great
yes
your avocation has become your vocation
uh and of course uh i believe that both
the microscope and the telescope were
invented by guys by the name of hans uh
uh at least i know that for the
telescope and uh that's because my my
good friend galileo galilei you know who
we just translated with frank wilczyk
and carlo ravalli and fabio legionati we
just made the first ever not translation
but but we did the first ever audio book
of galileo you can find that on my
website uh but he talks about insideris
nuncius you know how oh man you know he
just recently discovered a device that
came by way of the low country the
netherlands
and uh and i wonder you know i often
think about
you know what other instrument from the
telescope to the large hadron collider
to the microscope to crispr technology
is there any other technology that has
changed the universe our perception of
our place within it more than the
telescope
yeah i think
basically i think the telescope and
microscope are the two main instruments
because they just give us a view beyond
our natural scope of observation we have
some sort of biological and natural way
of looking at the world
so
to be able to see the very small and to
be able to see the very
big and very distant that's really
important and obviously the other thing
that has been very important in learning
our world is the
the possibility to go to other places
and funnily enough the netherlands
played an important role in that too
because the first seafarers and the
major explorers many of them were from
the low countries
and obviously today we are talking about
space flight and flying our spacecraft
to other planets and other satellites
but in the past it was visiting
other continents and other countries and
seeing things that you did not have at
home
i think these three things going to
other places going to look at other
scales very small
and going to look at very remote
distances like in cosmology and
astronomy
those may have been the biggest changes
in our
learning and and knowing about the world
and there's no shortage of uh dutch men
in this book uh which is called the
elephant in the universe we'll get to
that uh
as we go on but the uh the thing i love
to do with all the authors who honor us
with their presence on the into the
impossible podcast my
regular listeners will know this by
heart it's a game that we call
judging books by their covers
so this book
came with a a beautiful picture and a
very kind of um
maybe mysterious title unlike this book
which was uh written a couple years back
and has many many interesting
experiments and and things that we're
familiar with as i said past guests it
even has a forward bypass guest martin
reese on this book uh lord martin was on
the podcast not too long ago last year
and uh but this one has our good friend
avi loeb who is no stranger for
searching for things that no one's ever
seen before so go vert i want to ask you
a question
what is the meaning of the title of this
book what is the meaning of the picture
on the cover and uh and why did you
choose avi loeb of all people to uh to
grace it with a beautiful forward
yeah let's start with the last question
uh
the book was published by harvard
university press and avi is obviously
connected to harvard university and i
know him a little bit i interviewed him
for part of the book
and uh
i i have to say that i made a suggestion
to the publishers maybe we could ask him
to write a forward i uh i didn't like to
ask martin
again probably he probably would have
declined for a second time
and uh we all knew that um
that avi has been dealing with looking
for extraterrestrials and the whole
thing about
omuamua the visitor from outer space and
not everyone is taking his claims about
or his possibilities about
et too serious but i said well
in any case he's a famous name and it
might uh might push the sales of the
book because everybody knows who he is
and uh this book is not about aliens not
at all it's about a serious uh
uh scientific mystery
in which he is uh
dabbling a lot too so he is working on a
variety of theories on dark matter so we
decided this was safe to do and he was
happy to uh to to do that and then
working backwards with your three
questions
um
my publisher came up the designer at
harvard came up with the idea of not
using a traditional dark blue or black
cover for this book because almost every
astronomy book has a black cover or a
purple
and he thought maybe when we combine
this with with the starry background in
the elephant shape and then use all the
colors of the rainbow because it's it's
it attracts the attention so it's it's a
very
yeah i i like it very much so this is uh
this is the other thing
but then getting to your first question
about the title that's really an
interesting story
because it's a it's a broad topic uh
dark matter is about history it's about
physics particle physics cosmology
theory all kind of things
and yeah you could
call this book
searching for dark matter or whatever
you want to choose
but it was in fact my
european agent who came up with a
suggestion for this title and he said
i've been thinking about it and what
about the title the elephant in the
universe and i was immediately
enthusiastic for a couple of reasons
first of all
dark matter as most of your
viewers will know is
is about a lot of mass in the universe
it's about 85
of all the matter in the universe is
unknown to us it's dark it's mysterious
so it's a lot of mass so the elephant is
a good metaphor for that because it's a
very massive animal
but then obviously you also have these
connotations with with certain sayings
like the elephant in the room we all
know what we're talking about when
there's a big problem that's that is
mysterious but we sort of walk around it
we don't want to put our finger on it
and that's something that has been
happening in dark matter
research for a long time because as my
book shows in the first chapters it all
started out in the 1930s 1920s actually
about a century ago
and then in the 1940s and the 1950s and
most of the 60s not that much happened
about this riddle of dark matter people
knew about it and it just walked around
it like it was the elephant in the room
and finally there's also
a dutch saying i don't know if that's a
known saying in in
english too but we say uh the elephant
in the uh
in the porcelain
in the china cupboard that's what we're
saying elephant in the china cupboard
he's rambling around and destroying
everything
and
that's a nice connotation too because
this problem of dark matter may
may well
stir up all our current thinking about
the universe it may
lead us to to a whole new understanding
of physics and cosmology so i love the
title a lot it works very well in the in
dutch too the book has been translated
into the netherlands into dutch already
and it will also be at least the chinese
and the german edition so i think it's a
very good suggestion for my agent and in
combination with the cover and the
forward i like it a lot and i hope that
people who judge the book by the cover
will be attracted to it like dark matter
is attracting a lot of other material
universe
and no spoilers but you talk about in
the very beginning of the book so it's
not really a spoiler that we don't have
the answer uh what i loved about the
title go over actually the the subtitle
you say our um which is you know
inclusive which is nice but uh but also
uh it really kind of connotes the fact
that we are in this together this
mystery that we're trying to solve is a
global mystery it's a mystery
conversation through the ages through
time you start with the first person
who is dutch
captain i think is how you pronounce his
name uh who really coined the term in
english
and really did a lot of this work ort
obviously plays a role in the book as
well um and uh and so there is a dutch
um thread that runs throughout it uh not
not too overly uh heavy-handed but but
very nice and uh i only know one dutch
saying and it's what my late great
colleague hans parr
used to call me when i acted stupid he
said you are
in the clefenumolin does that make sense
clough in the moline
have you ever heard that hit with a
windmill
yeah i know the windmill so obviously i
don't know exactly what you were meaning
but i'd say a baby cough in the morning
okay
uh yeah you you got a uh hit by the uh
by one of the wings of the windmill yeah
so that would be pretty obvious you'd be
you'd be hard pressed not to notice if
you got hit by a windmill but um but
dark matter is very subtle and and we
don't know much about it as you say we
don't know the answer by the end of this
book but i wonder if we could start off
with um
maybe a different tact i've talked in my
show i've done videos which i'll link to
above
about the only type of dark matter that
we know for sure exists is the neutrino
but throughout the history of physics
people have done one of two things to
explain strange gravitational effects
they've postulated new forms of matter
yeah as is in the case of neptune the
prediction and discovery of neptune and
then they predicted new forces and
dynamical uh features of fields as in
the case of einstein explaining the
anomalous behavior of the perihelion of
mercury
today there's a lot in this book in
physics about new particles new forces
new fields
but not as much attention to uh to the
kind of outliers the the the maybe
somewhat out of left field as we say in
america uh suggestions of modifications
to not einstein but to newton can we
start with uh with an interview that you
did with uh monty mordecai milgram
in israel at weitzman and uh and his
theory and where does that stand now
first of all what is that theory is it
appealing um is there any point in
taking it seriously at this point
first describe the so-called modified
newtonian dynamics or mines
yeah well it's a very exciting and
interesting idea
because
milgram back in the
early 1980s i believe
he learned about this problem of dark
matter and he uh thought it was sort of
made up like we see particular movements
in galaxies and motions of stars and we
come up just with the solution by
proposing there's a lot of unseen
mysterious matter in the universe and he
thought well maybe i can also explain it
by
tuning the laws of gravity a little bit
and that was also
sort of
made up to to fit the answer so he came
up with a modification of newtonian
gravity
that's something i come back to in a
moment and he suggested a different kind
of
newtonian gravitational law and this
gravitational law that you come up with
could explain
the the weird rotational
properties of of spiral galaxies so he
said well maybe we're just
misunderstanding gravity and we need to
change that and not many people took
that too serious back then
but
even now
it has never been uh
written off so to say so
there is no observation there's no
clear indication that month as the
theory is known that it's it must be
wrong it's still a possibility that
there is some truth to it and that's
very
interesting because many other
alternative theories have been uh have
been ruled out over the decades and
milgram's theory still is a sort of a
viable theory and he has a
not a very big but a very loyal
group of scientists following in his
steps even a number of many of young
people young scientists who were maybe
more eager or more creative to embrace
these new kind of ideas and um there's
still some possibility that this might
be uh uh
the solution to the problem there's a
couple of things you ask what is the the
current status of month
one problem is it's a modification of
newtonian dynamics and it has turned out
to be very very difficult to get a
similar modification to einsteinian
gravity gravity and obviously we need to
do that because we know einstein is a
more
a better theory than newton so if you
want to change your theory of gravity in
the end you need to have a modification
of einstein the people are working on
that and
even a couple months ago there was a new
publication in
that direction but it's all very very
complicated and that means that the
theory of month has problems with
explaining everything that has to do
with einstein like explaining
gravitational lensing which is the
bending of light as described by
einstein's theory and also by explaining
even the
the expansion of the universe so there's
a couple of loose ends in month
but i have to say i i wrote at least one
one chapter on this
alternative theory for dark matter and i
talked to milgram and some of his
followers a lot
and i'm i've also always been intrigued
by this idea uh because
when you read about all these kind of
things and scientists thinking that they
that they know there must be this many
dark matter and we just
don't know what it is but we'll probably
find out as a reader
and certain as a non-academic or a hobby
astronomer that i was you always get
this feeling can that really be true and
then if there's one one single person
who comes up with a alternative theory
you feel some sympathy for him so even
back in the 1980s
i first read about milgram's theory and
i i thought yeah that's that sounds much
much more interesting and
the funny thing is it's still not ruled
out so
i don't know
another dutch physicist in amsterdam uh
eric frelinder is working on your new
alternative theory of gravity
still in very early stage but it has a
couple of
a couple of comparisons with milgram's
theory and also is an alternative theory
of explaining dark matter so who knows
what will happen in the next couple of
years right well uh of course milgram is
is israeli and the late great jacob
beckenstein was israeli and he came up
with a relativistic version called tevez
or taylor
tensor vector scalar um and so i'm gonna
not use a dutch phrase now but but a
hebrew phrase translated into english
which is you know proved to me uh the
the existence of dark matter while the
uh standing on one leg so to speak so
what is the most convincing
aspect of dark matter
to you
that um
motivates that we need it in the in the
universe i mean we can't see it we can't
smell it we can't touch it we haven't
detected it um what makes you and other
scientists rather uh believe in the
truth of its existence
it's a very uh interesting question
because there's a strange
uh change or evolution in the history of
science here when dark matter came up as
a problem for the first time in the past
century it was all about gravity and
motions and dynamics
the rotation curves of galaxies like the
outer parts of galaxies appear to move
too fast the motions of
galaxies and clusters
it was all about
the influence of gravity the
gravitational uh influence of of this
proposed dark matter and that's how i
learned about it for the first time
because i was interested in astronomy
and i read about all these kind of
things
but the interesting thing is
right now i believe that the most
compelling reason to believe so to say
in dark matter is not the rotation
curves of galaxies anymore it's not a
motion of galaxies and clusters it's the
cosmic background variation and you know
all about that and we have
we have studied and mapped the cmb in
such a high detail and with all the
statistical properties of these tiny
temperature fluctuations in cmb
people try to explain these statistical
properties and the only single only way
they can do that
is to introduce both dark matter and
dark energy and as soon as you change
the amount of mysterious dark matter
because we still don't know what it is
as soon as you change that by just a
percent or change the properties of this
mysterious dark energy a little bit
your
your calculations do not match the
observations of the cosmic uh microwave
background anymore so the funny thing is
if we did not have all these dynamical
uh uh
observations like rotation curves and
motions of galaxies if that had never
been observed even the c and b
observations of today would tell us
there must be a lot of dark matter in
the universe otherwise we can never go
from the universe back then as we
observe its properties in the cosmic
background radiation to the universe
right now with the observed distribution
of clusters and galaxies the only way
scientists are able to do that is
using the uh the gravity of dark matter
and i believe this is by now
and more of a physical
reason than a classical astronomical
reason to believe in it but that's the
most compelling reason to believe in the
stuff
yeah i i often point that out yeah we
hear a lot about rotation curves and and
of course you know zwiki is so prominent
in the discussion of it and whenever i
do a a discussion about dark matter and
i bring up um
vera rubin who spent not a small amount
of time here at uc san diego working
with her colleague margaret burbidge
and and her husband jeff burbidge but
margaret was really the observer that
taught vera rubin while she was on
sabbatical here in the 1960s uh how to
use a
spectrograph to take observations of
galaxies and
her work with ford who you interviewed
in this book veer's work uh really was
was definitive in many of our minds and
making the reality the case for its
reality uh even more so than dark energy
at least for a long time and yet you
know the fact that we've known about
dark
matter for so much longer since the you
know since captain maybe but but also
you know since wiki
and had evidence for its existence um i
wonder you know is there a point in
which you would counsel my colleagues uh
some of whom are here uh like uh like
kaishawan knee who helps co-run the
xenon experiment with your friend and my
friend elena april and past guests but
um
when would you tell a physicist you
gotta stop this experiment i mean you
don't keep running you know once you
detect the uh the bottom quark they
don't just keep running it and and and
getting more and more decimal places is
there or would there ever come a point
where you go over it would tell
my colleagues your your friends that you
interview in this book stop the search
it's not it's not going to pan out
yeah it's that's a very hard question
because it i will make a comparison to
another interesting thing and and that's
the search for
alien technology extraterrestrial life
the seti search to search for accessible
intelligence we've never found it and
then you can say well let's stop it
because it's it's we probably will never
find it but the other thing is that the
people who do the search will tell you
oh man but we've just started we are
only just beginning we uh there's so
many uh uh
areas to explore and i think for the
physical
the particle physics search for dark
matter is more or less the same so it
would be hard for me to tell
professional
scientists oh you better stop because
you will probably never find but the
thing is
they will have to stop
searching for it by the way they do it
right now like the xenon experiments
with these big underground laboratories
where they try to find
the very rare interactions of dark metal
particles with with
with atom atomic nuclei they will have
to stop because if these instruments get
about and they have been increa
increasing in sensitivity over the years
many many times but if they increase the
sensitivity more than 10 times over the
current value
and the signal from dark matter would be
below that they will never find it
because neutrinos which you mentioned
before will take over and at that very
low level of signal neutrinos are
everywhere and they will
sort of disturb your experiment
and if dark matter is so elusive that
you will not find it by the next
generation of xenon experiments
then
this way of looking for it will have to
stop because it doesn't make sense
so
the the xenon scientists the particle
physicists who are looking for it by
this kind of experiment they really hope
that this next generation will give
their answer because otherwise
they're out of uh out of the game and
they have to find other ways to to look
for this mysterious stuff so maybe it's
it's nature itself who tells us when and
where to stop
very good so reminder we're talking uh
with governor chilling who's a favorite
of author of mine he's author of dozens
of books articles you find them inside
and
in the sky and telescope and many other
things he won the david schramm award
from the american astronomical society
and in 2007 he got his own piece of dark
matter named after him uh an asteroid
called a one zero nine eight six gobert
in his honor uh it's such a it's such a
delight to talk to you so uh i am
reminded of of a book by or maybe it's a
saying i think it's a book by sherlock
holmes a great mystery writer
and it was called the dog that didn't
bark and it's all about you know how you
can notice something by its absence not
necessarily looking for its presence so
what's so unusual about a dog that
doesn't bark well i mean i think a lot
of it is is you know kind of in the in
the sense that of all the things we know
really well and of course you know that
people criticize astronomers at least
from the you know maybe unorthodox side
but say oh well you don't know what 95
percent of the universe is made up of
why should i listen to you about the
earth being around and all these other
nonsense that we talk so
i find some of the strongest evidence
for dark matter comes from our our
exquisite knowledge about ordinary
matter baryonic matter the matter that
makes up uh you and you and me and and
the in this in your asteroid and
everything else the protons the neutrons
yeah i always say the croutons
my favorite edible uh edible particle
the pion which is made of pies i think
but but you know we know so much about
ordinary matter and i want to talk about
the tools and what what is sort of of
all the your you're kind of this um uh
traveler in this book this hero making a
journey to conferences during covet and
different countries different continents
uh and uh of all the different tools and
technologies which one is sort of um the
most interesting maybe one coming in the
future you talk about axion searches
what is about the technology is it the
computer is it the supercomputer inside
of our skull what technology is the most
you know exciting uh if not you know
most promising but most interesting to
you personally yeah
well first of all we certainly do not
have a super computer in our skull i
think our brain is pretty limited and
that's and it's very good that you
mentioned the computer revolution
because without the computer revolution
most of uh today's signs could not have
been done at all i mean the the big
particle accelerators and even the xenon
experiments they produce such a huge
amount of computing instruments to to
even uh search through the data to find
what you're looking for
but in terms of experiments it's it's a
good question because
again my background is in astronomy so i
know telescopes and i've been to many
observatories all over the world and
i've been impressed by
big well i've been at your experiment at
the south pole which was a
very very interesting trip obviously so
that people are
able and and
to to build and construct and think up
these kind of experiments in such remote
places or like the alma observatory at
five kilometers altitude above sea level
in chile these are all extremely
impressive but
in preparing this book i paid a visit to
the big cern laboratory in switzerland
the big particle physics celebora 3
and
i
have always been impressed by big
astronomical instruments they might be
as big as as a car
behind the telescope but here at cern we
have an experiment a detector which is
as big
as as a castle it's it's a huge thing
it's it's it's about the mass of the of
the notre dame in paris and it's uh
all filled up with wires and detectors
and electronics and to see that in
action is incredibly impressive and i
think that when you
when you think about understanding
the matter that we are all made of we
have made such giant leaps over the past
decades using these kind of experiments
that's really tremendously impressive to
me because
i think finding out more about
normal matter
may well be the way of
solving the riddle of dark matter
because after all it's all part of part
of one universe part of one nature
nature doesn't care what we call it
nature just has a bunch of particles and
the fact that we have not discovered all
of them and called some of them dark
matter
nature doesn't care it's just a complete
completes uh well a system of particles
and forces so maybe
the solution to this problem may come
from the more or less regular
experiments in particle physics and
as you uh you and your listeners
probably know over the past year there
has been a couple of
observations that there might be hints
of a possible fifth force in the in
nature because muons the the nephews of
normal electrons are behaving a little
bit strange and if this really pans out
and it turns out to be uh
to be uh
seen by other experiments too this may
well lead us to a new understanding of
the uh
of the uh
of our current understanding of the uh
of particle physics and it may well lead
to a better understanding of dark matter
too yeah
um what is it like to write a book where
the story is not as you know cleanly
wrapped up as it was in this book you
know you nobel prize award you know
which i often talked about in in
negative terms is kind of like uh false
history of the of not your book but but
it gives a distorted impression about
you know what what are the stakes
involved and in this book there is no
conclusion i'm asking for myself because
you know we're involved in documentaries
and things about the cmb and you can
find those online um and and it's always
about the promise of the future and this
current book the elephant in the
universe has an awful lot of promise for
the future but as you said there is an
ultimate stop sign the cosmic neutrino
background or the supernova um relic
neutrino background how is it to write a
book where there is no you know tidy
ending and chat and you know the third
act of the of the of the play how did
how did you handle that ambiguity
there's a fun story here i think i
mentioned it in my in my introduction
because in the late in the in the mid
1990s
i was doing research for a book on
accessor planets because i knew there
are new experiments and maybe within a
couple of years they will find the first
planet and then
well let's start researching the book
and
even before i started writing the first
exercise planet was discovered so i had
to hurry up producing that book which
has never been published in the united
states by the way but you have many
exoplanet books there by your own and
then a couple of years later with the
with the gravitational wave book the
ripples in space-time book that you just
showed it's it was more or less the same
because there would be a second
generation of
the gravitational wave detectors and
coming online soon and i thought well
when they start to do their measurements
maybe within three or four years we will
have the detection of gravitational
waves so i started to work on this book
and bang
right after they switched the detector
on they found the first gravitational
wave and again i had to hurry
but in both cases of these two books
the the real discovery was in the book
obviously and that was good so when i
started to think about the dark matter
book and i talked to all these
scientists i jokingly said to them
well you got to prepare yourself because
when i start writing a book the
scientists usually make the final
discovery and that didn't happen
and
it's it's hard brian i i know it's
difficult because you want to go to a
climax you want to
make the story complete and it didn't
happen in this case and it was prepared
for that
so
what i tried to do and i hope i
succeeded what i try to do is give
people
a feeling of how it is to work on a
search where you do not know
what the final goal uh where the final
uh route will be you you will you do not
know whether or not you will be
successful but
you need this passion and this uh
uh yeah this this
uh this this this way of going on with
with this kind of experiments to to be
able to do it and
what i
what i hope that i have done is
throughout the book
people who were
looking for dark matter they came up
with new experiments they came up with
new observational technology they come
up with new theories and all these
experiments and technologies and
theories have given us a much broader
vision of our universe and it's about
the distribution of matter in the
universe and it's about the cmb and it's
about distant galaxies and it's about
the makeup of galaxies and the formation
of structure in the universe and all
those kind of topics have been
dealt with by people who were interested
in solving the dark matter mystery
so even if we will never find dark
matter
it has been a way
of discovering our universe and in a
sense i will make that comparison again
in a sense it's like
searching for extraterrestrial life
we have not found it yet and maybe we
will not find it in our lifetime and
maybe we will never find it
but looking for extraterrestrial life
has given us esther biology that has
given us extrasolar planets it has given
us chemical evolution of the
universe it has given us the
knowledge of about the origin of our
solar system so maybe we need such big
mysteries as a drive
to push forward our
our understanding of the universe and
hopefully that will happen with uh with
this topic too yeah absolutely um going
back to my uh predilection for
discussing
aberrations or perhaps uh iconic class
or uh unorthodox topics in this uh book
uh is the story of the dhamma experiment
which
is has fascinated me for 25 years and i
imagine many other people as well uh i
don't have many criticisms of this book
that you've written
but uh but if there's one i would have
loved to have seen even more kind of
psychological uh uh discussion of what's
going on in these people's minds we have
this experiment that claims something
like what go over 13 sigma
evidence for dark matter not only for
dark matter but for an annual modulation
of the signal talk about what it was
like to talk to these people i i get i'm
and i'm only teasing i don't criticize
the book at all but someone like harry
collins you know gets into the sociology
of of uh of scientists maybe i can
convince him to to do a book about this
collaboration someday but maybe he
wouldn't get anywhere because they're so
secretive right so talk about what is
the dhamma experiment what is the annual
modulation which was predicted by uh
past guests on the show and good friends
of mine and collaborators on the simon's
observatory katie freeze and and david
spurgle um talk about dhamma what is
annual modulation why should we care and
what is going on maybe speculate on why
they are so
perhaps
unwilling to share their data and
results
okay so dhamma stands for dark matter
it's just an abbreviation
and it's an experiment run by italian
physicists and it's based in italy in
the grand social laboratory which is
deep in the epinephrine mountains
away from all the cosmic disturbances
that you may get and it's the same
location where also the the big
international xenon experiment is based
so
there are a lot of dark matter
experiments going on there now what i
claim to have found is this
when when our milky way galaxy
is is uh
is situated in inside a big halo of dark
matter these particles must be all
around us and
our solar system is moving through this
cloud of uh
of dark matter particles so you should
see a certain sort of flux of dark
matter particles that's what xenon also
tries to find the dark metaparticles
that that are supposedly all around us
now what dharma says
our earth is also circling around the
sun
so sometimes when the sun is moving in
this direction through the galaxy and
our earth is circling around the sun
sometimes they're moving in the same
direction and some in the opposite
direction so the flux of dark matter
particles should show a tiny variation
over the year and that's something that
people had predicted a couple of decades
ago
and
people have been looking for it and
never found it and now here comes this
tiny dharma experiment and they claim
they have found this signal
so you would suppose when they first
presented their results that everybody
would say yeah we have found it finally
and the problem has been resolved but
that's not how science works scientists
will always when you hear a
proposed solution it will also always be
critical and it will
they will ask the scientists
maybe you did this wrong or maybe your
analysis is wrong or
let us do a second experiment to see if
we can confirm it
and the dhamma experimentalists have
always been a little bit secretive about
their
about their experiments in the sense
that they
produced their final conclusions they
published their final conclusions and
their conclusions seem to be very
very convincing as you said
many sigma results but they have never
they have never been willing to produce
their
raw data so that other people could do
their own analysis on the data to see if
they come up with the same results
the other thing that i found which was a
little bit of a surprise to me i thought
i am this science journalist i'm not a
competing scientist i'm not involved
with any other experiment i'm just a
neutral science journalist doing a book
on this project
dear italian dharmaphysis you claim to
have found dark matter i'll give you a
call let's make an appointment for an
interview and i will visit your
experiment and we talk about it you can
explain all to me and it will be a big
chapter in my book
and the response was when i emailed the
leader of this project the response was
no we never do oral interviews with
journalists the only way we be in touch
with you will be answering your
questions through email
and well as you can tell from the tell
from the discussion we have right now
the way we are discussing uh my book
right now would never be possible by
exchanging questions and answers through
email so
when i send them a list of questions
pretty critical questions pretty uh
informative questions
they came up with very basic answers
like one or two sentences and it didn't
make yeah it didn't help me at all to
to learn more about it
so i think that the biggest criticism
of the dharma scientists is not
their publications
but it's the the fact that nobody can
check how they came up with these
published results because they they keep
the data to themselves
they have not been willing to tell too
much about the setup of their
experiments and by now
we have a big problem because you would
say well if the hammer finds this that
there must be something to it
but obviously there can be many kind of
other influences that may create a
spurious annual variation in this signal
and if dhamma is correct
and if their annual modulation is due to
dark matter
that would tell you the amount of dark
matter would be at a certain level
and if it really is at that level
the current version of the xenon
experiment would easily detect it and it
detects none right and then the other
thing is a couple of uh scientists have
reproduced the dharma experiment as best
as they can
and
one of these experiments is based in the
uh in the
pyrenees between spain and france
also in the mountains and they published
their first results about half a year or
a year ago and they don't see any annual
variation at all
so
not many people are convinced about it
and it's it's a shame because this is a
valid experiment and
everybody would love to work together
with these italian scientists to to
solve the riddle and
maybe it will keep going like this for a
long time
yeah and i think you know one of the
hallmarks of a good scientist i'm not
casting aspersions on them but just
speaking generally is that you want
criticism you want attention even if
it's negative because that makes your
discovery anti-fractional it makes it
robust it makes it immune to
a two future attacks and solidifies it
in the scientific canon now one way they
could do that is to do what good
scientists have always known is that
there's more than one way to get any
signal including uh going back to
the galileo and his prediction about the
tides and how he thought about it and
was completely wrong as i point out and
he could have done a simple measurement
as he did to prove uh aristotle wrong
that heavier objects fall faster than
lighter ones so it's doing experiments
and it's accounting for what are called
systematic so there's a fundamental
irreducible noise you can only reduce by
taking more data and that's called
statistical noise statistical errors and
then there's so-called systematic errors
which are either associated with your
instrument the system
or the environment in which it's in or
the planet which it's on
and or you know where it is in the
galaxy is in the case of bicep too and
and the signal that we later
retracted our claim that it was due to
inflation and more the from the presence
of dust in the milky way gallery which
by the way you can get if you're in
america i am on my mailing list join it
and you live in the us i will send you
some space dust which is the villain of
my book and that's at briankeating.com
list check that out check out gopher
chilling's website we'll have links to
all that in the show notes down below
but um but in the case of dama they
could easily show that it's not
systematic errors by repeating these uh
sodium ion diet experiment in the
southern hemisphere right i mean that
would give an antivaria but they've not
yet done that other teams i understand
are um what do you make of and you
mentioned the liquid xenon detectors
that are also uh obviously hot on and
have really obliterated uh much of the
competition including my uh favorite you
know previous experiments which were
like the cds ms experiments the the the
germanium uh and silicon detectors so
now those have just been wiped off the
map by people like my friend richard
gatesgill and elena april
talk about what you call the xenon wars
this is a very actual i didn't know this
about uh you know you always assume your
friends are friends with each other but
uh that could not be farther from the
truth in certain cases uh elena is is
one of my favorite scientists she we did
we did an event here right before the
pandemic with her right around her
birthday in march of 2020 and that was
called chasing einstein and that was
with filmmaker
from la that that
has done such wonderful work on that
documentary
talk about elena her personality the the
kind of italian and there are a lot of
italians that work in dark matter a lot
of italian women
which is really cool but talk about um
talk about her personality maybe what
she what you observe from her lessons
that she learned from her experience
with rubia nobel laureate and other uh
approaches but also her kind of
obsession in some ways and i have teased
her about that you know that she fixates
on this nobel prize and she really wants
to detect it uh and and does so as a you
know with the with the greatest
experimental you know equipment team
ideas and skills that she has talk about
her personality talk about this xenon
what you call the xenon wars
yeah i think uh elena abril is one of
the most intriguing persons who i met in
researching this book
i have to say that before i started
researching this book i had
i had read about the xenon experiment
but it didn't know that the people
involved very much as it was more
particle physics than astronomy so when
he understood that he was leading this
experiment ever since the start of this
century i thought well i need to visit
her and look her up in new york where
she lives and
i did that and it was a
very exciting um
and interesting uh day that we did we
met in her brooklyn apartment and she
talked about all the history and what i
learned from her was how important it is
to be really passionate about what you
want to
to reach ever since she was a young girl
she had set her mind on becoming a
famous physicist and every time the goal
was
higher and higher and when she worked on
uh on certain detectors for uh detecting
gamma rays from from space
she realized that maybe that is not
something in which there is
a big discovery space left anymore i'm
not sure if that's true but but around
that time when she was doing this kind
of experiments you learned about dark
matter for the first time uh even
particle physicists sometimes do not
know about what other colleagues were
working on and when she heard about this
problem she got hooked on solving the
problem of dark matter especially since
her work with noble gases would
make it possible to
to work on this kind of xenon detectors
that she helped develop
so she changed careers and she
she applied for national science
foundation money and she received it and
she built up her own research group and
started with it with a very tiny
test experiment in her lab a tabletop
experiment more or less and she has been
working and working all the time and as
soon as one experiment is being
becomes operational
work is already
going on on the next version of the
experiment so she just will never give
up and
what what excites me about this is
is what will happen
i i hope not for her but what will
happen if the
xenon
development as i said before when it
becomes 10 or a couple of tens of times
more sensitive
it won't work anymore because neutrinos
will take over the uh
the signal level
what will you do when you have spent
decades of your professional career in
in improving this technique and
searching and looking for it hoping that
you will make the final discovery and it
will not happen that that must be a big
psychological shock so we talked about
all this and part of it uh what where
what was the reason why i
uh when i uh mentioned
why i gave this chapter the title of the
xenon wars
is that there's not just one group uh
she used to work with with rick gatskell
whom you just mentioned and with a
couple of other american scientists so
it's really an international experiment
a lot of dutch people too
her own husband was involved in this
project too but then uh gateskill and a
couple of his colleagues they thought
well italy is far away and we have some
other things of thinking how we can do
it and maybe we can set up our own
experiments also using xenon same kind
of technology so they split and it was
not a real war but it was not a nice
story too because when you have a big
research group and some people in your
group say well we don't want to
cooperate anymore and we set up our own
group that's
uh well it's complicated let's call it
that way and then there was a third
group in in china where her husband went
to after they they got their divorce
already so it's really
it's really a mix of personal relations
and colleagues that were friends of you
and even your your
ex-husband whom you have worked with and
then suddenly you are all
more or less competing because you're
working with the same kind of technology
the same kind of uh of goal and all of
you hope to be the first one to make
this
uh this important discovery so
i'm really
uh
yeah i was amazed by
by elena april's
passion and her
her perseverance in in this whole
project and it's probably the same for
other kind of people i i also
interviewed rick gateskill who was a
very nice person to talk to
and unfortunately because of the covert
pandemic i could not visit the new
laboratory that's now being constructed
in the united states it's not
it's i think it has become operational
around this time so it's finished in any
way but yeah all the all the experiments
are in the book and i think uh maybe
you you might say maybe despite this
competition or maybe thanks to this
competition the xenon experiments might
well play an important role in solving
the riddle absolutely yeah and and i
think about uh yet another
kind of uh saying that you just
mentioned you know you want to be the
first to get there um but often um you
know we speak about the first mover
advantage in business and constructing
things but sometimes the last mover you
know in the case of galileo
everybody knows galileo's name nobody
knows hans lippershay's name
unfortunately for the dutch uh but
they're you know that that's that's okay
in other words it's not the person who
you know maybe initially had the idea
it's the person who makes the definitive
ultimate measurement or utilization of
that tool and i wonder you know if we
can you know maybe close with the
opening
character in this book who couldn't be
more
different than the fiery elena april or
the or the uh wonderfully uh you know
kind of whimsical richard gateskill and
that's uh and that's
jim peebles who you begin the book with
and once about eight nine years ago jim
gave a colloquium here at uc san diego
and i spent the day with him and it was
so much fun and in the uh colloquium you
know he started talking about things you
know that that
in his gentle canadian way that he has
uh about uh you know where do we go from
here to to detect things like this or to
to constrain them and i said you know
there's so many competing theories and
and it's all just you know so
bewildering and he actually told me to
shut up can you believe that he said he
said shut up and measure he didn't say
shut up
to me
insulting me but i'll always treasure
the time that nobel laureate uh jim
peebles told yours truly brian keating
to shut up um talk about you know that
philosophy that really we should be kind
of um agnostic uh to use a loaded word
but uh we should be agnostic
as to what the dark matter might be and
it could surprise us uh he he in his
early papers which you uh really
delightfully um uh unravel for me as a
professional scientist
you know we never i don't have the time
to read the papers that came out today
let alone the paper that was written the
year i was born
you know start to make the case for for
cold dark matter but um
what what is your philosophy should we i
mean in an era of constrained budgets uh
you know where you just talked about
three different experiments lux panda
xena they're all go i mean can we just
say you know that that you know we
should all get along we should all make
a measurement or is it really just worth
the competition is good in and of itself
in the case of dhamma how did you how do
you emerge from this this wonderful
story which which doesn't have the nice
neat golden you know picture of alfred
nobel at the end of it um but talk about
you know the theory of in the spirit of
jim peoples what would you think we
should do going forward more experiments
more theory more computation what's the
best opportunity it's
finding a very very difficult question
if it was an easy question everybody
would know the answer and we would be
doing that already
and again i'm not in a position to to
judge the scientist or the or the uh
or the um the people who provide the
money so it's all connected in that way
but
at some point in in what you just said
you you talked about we need to be
agnostic and not having this particular
view of what dark matter should be and
that's very very hard because we are all
people we are all uh loaded with history
and and and and our current view of
physics and and of the science we're
working in
so i think it's very important to be
uh to be open and to have an open mind
to new
uh
new angles and new new discoveries and
the people who are best in being open
are the young people
because uh as soon as you are 25 or 26
or 27 you you start to lose your
creativity and you get too much um
influenced by uh by the world around you
and so i think the creative ideas by
young people are very important here and
maybe the best thing we could do
is uh
is is even at an earlier stage maybe
already at high school or at elementary
school and to train
our children to be creative in their
thoughts and to be
to be
real
scientific thinkers and to think out of
the box and to know how it works how to
check a scientific theory or a
particular idea and to to learn which is
important in these days of fake news and
and and
all kind of things that we now have to
learn um what you can trust and what
what kind of measurements are necessary
to
to to really be convinced by something
and if we
train the younger generation of being
better scientists and to be
much more creative than than the older
generation who are all spending their
careers in a particular direction and
and maybe not so eager to to
to change gears anymore
yeah maybe that will help us forward and
it's it's both in theory
and in experiments there are a lot of
young creative minds and new
technologies that come around and that
may give us the possibility of dreaming
up new experiments to solve this
particular problem i'm i'm certain that
there will be a solution to the dark
matter problem i hope to be
alive when it's when it will arrive
and uh it might be extremely interesting
if it's something completely unexpected
actually i would love that
but even if it's just another
strange particle which is not that uh
unexpected it might be a very
interesting find and i'm sure we will
eventually get there if we have the
creative minds and if we feed the
creative minds to uh go on with this but
that's difficult uh to
to not be
influenced by uh by common knowledge so
to say yeah
well gilbert this has been a delight a
treat for me
you're a delightful writer
you always inspire me to look deeper
into mysteries that i might take for
granted you're not afraid to be
technical but you write with a a poet uh
and and kind of the delightful prose
that
is rare in scientific so-called pop
popular science um so i want to thank
you we've been talking today with
governor schilling author of ripples in
spacetime with an endorsement by lord
martin reese on the front of it a
forward by him and by uh today's book we
discuss the elephant in the universe
what is it is it a tusk is it a rope is
it a is it a tree what is the elephant
in the universe you will find out more
about this stalking elephant
pachyderm that is lurking in the
universe when you read this wonderful
book go over where can people find you
online
uh i'm active on twitter it's just my
twitter handle is just my first and last
name strung together go for shilling
i have my own
website but it's basically in dutch
obviously but all the stories that i
write for english language magazines
like sky telescope that you mentioned or
sky at night in the uk you can find my
english language articles there too
but i look forward to meeting your
podcast viewers on uh
on twitter or uh whenever and maybe in
the future in person yeah i'll be great
thanks very much for having me brian it
was a pleasure talking to you and thanks
for your kind words about my book thank
you so much for coming on gilbert be
well
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable and magical
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye